versus has searched the many possible
futures of the multiverse to bring
together two retired heavyweights Dark
Knight Returns Batman vs Kingdom Come
Superman in one corner we've got Frank
Miller's grizzled guardian of Gotham
Batman don't underestimate this more
mature Dark Knight he's just as
determined and strategically savvy as he
was in his prime in the other corner
stands Mark Waid and Alex Ross's paragon
of purity Superman looks like a fine
wine this version of the Man of Steel
proves that Kryptonians only get better
with age at 55 years young Bruce Wayne
isn't lacking much from the good old
days
in fact his private arsenal has only
gotten more impressive with heavy
artillery like a monstrous bat tank and
a state-of-the-art armored bat suit and
with the mind still as sharp as a
Batarang Bruce is a one-man army capable
of concrete any competitor 10 years
inside the fortress of solitude was the
perfect respite for Supes to become even
more powerful impossible as it may seem
he's stronger than his younger self and
a years of absorbing radiation from
Earth's Sun have rendered him
invulnerable to kryptonite with Clark's
physical shortcomings erased a victory
seems inevitable
Batman will have to outsmart Superman to
win but you can always count on Bruce
for an ingenious Master Plan in Dark
Knight 3 he neutralizes an entire army
of kandorians using a complex system of
drones that make the clouds rain
synthetic kryptonite that's the kind of
technical brilliance that could bring
Superman to his knees if you're curious
what it takes to subdue Kingdom Come
Superman
check out 2007 Justice Society of
America 10 in order to save a suicidal
teen Clark overcomes the combined might
of the Justice Society plus the crushing
strength of star man's gravity powers
this is a Superman who simply cannot be
chained
alas batman is only human and the years
have made him a half-step slower and
just a bit weird but if Bruce can limit
the physical demands of the fight
Alfred will be drawing him an ice bath
in no time the Man of Steel's weakness
is all mental and he's much quicker to
outrage and recklessness in his old age
but if Superman can keep his temper in
check an angular red s is the last thing
Batman will see these iconic versions of
Bruce and Clark rocked their own
universes as the ultimate heroes but who
will be left standing
when else worlds collide Batman or Super
Bowl let us know who you're betting on
in the comments below that's this week's
battle for the multiverse so head down
to the comments and tell us who you
think would win and why and we are
always looking for ideas for the next
verses so make sure you let us know who
you want to see faceoff next have a
great weekend and we'll see you next
time Superfriends bye-bye